[Música]
hola soy re blanco para mí es un placer
saludarlos en esta oportunidad en esta
serie de informes quebraban continuación
sobre el manejo que le han dado a las
autoridades suecas a la pandemia de
coronavirus este país escandinavo ha
puesto en práctica una estrategia única
y controvertida para hacer frente al coi
19 a diferencia de otros países europeos
suecia nunca ha impuesto el
confinamiento y las escuelas
restaurantes y negocios han permanecido
abiertos incluso en el punto más álgido
de la crisis sanitaria hoy en día el uso
de mascarillas ni siquiera es
recomendado por las autoridades nuestros
corresponsales fueron a interrogar a los
suecos para saber lo que piensan de la
política aplicada por su gobierno
los últimos rayos de sol se reflejan en
el mar cristalino de las afueras de
estocolmo los suecos están fuera para
disfrutar del final del verano todas las
generaciones están reunidas sin máscaras
walking train golf
salgo a pasear juego al golf
veo amigos creo que ha sido un buen
momento a pesar de todo
en suecia no tenemos muchos casos ahora
mismo vio a la libertad en suecia y
consejos para combatir la pandemia pero
pocas reglas cada quien es responsable
ni siquiera se recomiendan las
mascarillas mantener la distancia
lavarse las manos porque eso no es lo
que nosotros hacemos el pueblo sueco
hace lo que se le dice o digamos la
mayoría de los suecos una estrategia
menos restrictiva pero percibida como
más duradera hippie nets dejar que las
cosas sean lo más normal posible te da
la fuerza para aguantar más tiempo la
gente se cansa y no estoy segura de que
puedan seguir para siempre
puedes quedarte encerrado en casa para
siempre no es posible así que creo que
nuestra estrategia es la correcta
las nuevas tasas de contagios en suecia
han bajado a alrededor de 300 por día
proporcionalmente 20 veces más bajas que
en francia y ya se está desarrollando un
nuevo tipo de turismo
hemos huido de la obligación de llevar
máscara en alemania aquí puedes sentarte
en la terraza de un café sin máscara
caminar sin máscaras es genial ver a la
gente riendo y sonriendo es una libertad
que tiene un precio suecia ha tenido 10
veces más muertes que finlandia y
noruega los dos países vecinos
y es que durante la primavera el número
de muertos en suecia aumentó mucho más
que en las naciones vecinas el virus
afectó especialmente a los hogares de
ancianos es por eso que nuestros
corresponsales interrogaron a los suecos
para averiguar si el gobierno para ellos
hizo lo suficiente para proteger a sus
adultos mayores
era como mi padre mi tío siempre estuvo
ahí para mí por eso ahora estoy luchando
por él porque sé que no aceptaría esto
estaría realmente enojado
moises en tanda tenía 72 años cuando
murió de kobe 19 en un hogar de ancianos
su familia presentó un informe policial
en el que señaló varias irregularidades
en su cuidado alcohol
llamamos a su tío por face time y
pudimos ver al personal detrás de él nos
llevaban máscaras ni iguanas sufría de
demencia el 12 de abril contrajo el
virus y cuatro días después murió
el médico nos dijo que estaban siguiendo
ciertos protocolos para los ancianos y
mi tío era tan mayor y también débil
ellos no reciben atención hospitalaria
ehlers sólo eran analgésicos jones no le
daban oxígeno
y básicamente se asfixiado mientras
dormía porque no podía respirar
sentí que sacrificaron a los ancianos y
eso está muy mal porque creo que debes
darles a todos la oportunidad de
sobrevivir
moises falleció dentro de esta
residencia estatal en estocolmo
las autoridades locales nos dijeron que
no pueden comentar sobre el casos
específicos pero que siguieron las
instrucciones oficiales los médicos
evaluaron individualmente a los
residentes mayores aunque a veces en
línea o por teléfono
suecia ha registrado más de 5.800
muertes por kobe 19 casi la mitad en
hogares de ancianos científicos
destacados han criticado el enfoque de
las autoridades
que no intentaron salvar sus vidas
tenían miedo de que las unidades de
cuidados intensivos colapsaran no
pudieran cuidar a los jóvenes que
estaban gravemente enfermos por lo que
estaban seleccionando y creo que con
demasiada dureza
la muerte de miles de personas mayores
conmocionó a suecia y en julio el primer
ministro anunció una investigación
pública para determinar por qué hubo
tantas víctimas de kobe 19 en los
hogares de ancianos del país
una notable diferencia en la forma que
suecia manejó la pandemia fue que todas
las escuelas para menores de 16 años
permanecieron abiertas las autoridades
de salud del país sostienen que eso no
aumentó las infecciones entre los niños
aunque para algunos la decisión podría
haber causado un aumento en el número de
contactos en el país que es alrededor de
10 veces más alto que las naciones
vecinas
los niños de suecia van a la escuela tal
y como lo han hecho durante la pandemia
de kobe 19 aquí las clases han sido
continuas y obligatorias para todos los
alumnos hasta la edad de 16 años sin
usar mascarillas
creo que es bueno que en realidad no
lleven mascarillas tengo tres hijos y
creo que es importante que vayan a la
escuela de lo contrario me sería muy
difícil trabajar conforme
[Música]
las medidas de higiene se han
intensificado el personal considera que
mantenerse operativos es esencial
especialmente para los estudiantes con
dificultades de mira este sitio
necesitan los maestros la misma sala que
ellos para animarlos y aclararles las
dudas de estos estudiantes la mayoría de
las veces no piden ayuda simplemente se
sientan y esperan hasta que alguien se
les acerque y ramón camps soft ciudad a
diferencia de muchos estudiantes en
europa estos alumnos no han perdido un
solo día de clases debido al coronavirus
las autoridades sanitarias tomaron la
decisión de mantener abiertas las
escuelas y se mantuvieron firmes incluso
cuando la tasa de mortalidad aquí era
diez veces más alta que en otros países
nórdicos vecinos de suecia
mi papá tenía coronavirus cuando llegó
por primera vez a suecia estuvo enfermo
durante seis semanas mi papá también
estuvo enfermo durante ocho semanas
estoy feliz de que nos cerramos al
principio cuando la gente tenía que
ponerse en cuarentena yo pensaba porque
no tenemos cuarentena realmente no lo
entendía no sabía qué pasaría si me
enfermaba ahora cuando se más no me
siento insegura
no me siento en riesgo porque no soy
vieja
aquí 20 de 70 maestros contrajeron
coronavirus entre ellos la subdirectora
futuro y ser convocado durante tres
semanas no pude levantarme de la cama no
podía comer no podía dormir no podía
caminar estaba muy enferma creo que hice
un sacrificio
pero creo que valió la pena porque se
trata de nuestros hijos y son lo más
importante que tenemos
ochocinco un riesgo que vale la pena
correr una encuesta de opinión mostró un
60 por ciento de confianza en el manejo
de la pandemia por parte de las
autoridades
echamos ahora un vistazo a un posible
tratamiento para el coronavirus que se
está desarrollando en un laboratorio en
estocolmo la idea podría salvar
incontables vidas si pasa a las
siguientes etapas de pruebas se basa en
inyectar inofensivamente a una alpaca
con el virus y luego cosechar sus
anticuerpos para usarlos en humanos les
aseguramos que ninguna alpaca fue
lastimada en la elaboración de este
informe
estamos en el prestigioso instituto
karolinska de estocolmo que otorga el
premio nobel de medicina en el interior
científicos trabajan en pruebas y
vacunas contra el kobe 19 pero también
en un tratamiento pionero con la ayuda
de un peludo amigo
tyson la alpaca
este es tyson tiene los anticuerpos
contra el virus arco 2
a los camellos las alpacas llamas y
otros animales de esa familia tienen
anticuerpos especiales de cadena simple
pequeños anticuerpos que han demostrado
poder bloquear el cob y 19
esta es la llave que abre la cerradura
que introduce el virus en la célula pero
hemos puesto este nano cuerpo encima y
eso lo bloquea y si podemos hacer esto
en un paciente evitaremos que el
paciente desarrolle la enfermedad
a partir de muestras de sangre los
investigadores pueden clonar anticuerpos
en grandes cantidades no para producir
una vacuna sino un tratamiento que
surgirá con más probabilidad como un
spray bucal o inhalador estos nano
cuerpos son muy pequeños y muy fáciles
de producir estamos muy emocionados de
haber encontrado algo que es muy
operativo aunque aún sigue en la etapa
experimental con la financiación
adecuada el tratamiento podría estar
listo a mediados de 2021
hasta aquí la serie de france 24 un
placer acompañarlos
nos vemos en una próxima oportunidad
[Música]